all right guys we got ourselves a final
trailer for The Flash you make sure to
leave a like we gotta get right to it
and also this video we have a sponsor
from a game that I ended up loving more on
them after the video it's dizzy speedstorm
I love you thank you passing you into Mr White
damn wowie so you're saying you could travel back
in time yep I can fix things save people save my
mom save your parents oh no that is tempting
huh you can also destroy everything yeah
everything I love you too so how was it
this week how's school Google was good
this is mad trippy dude this is catastrophic
this world must die
Pink Floyd I'm not gonna lose her again
I will help you interesting groups want some help
wait he's Batman God damn right he's
Batman you want to get nuts let's get nuts
I was cutting edge slang wow
damn sure so much of Ben Affleck yeah let's go
oh man
you have fancy friends the iris yeah
I think so he's an Uber oh exactly
is that Uber black I did buy some tickets I got
tickets everyone went to early screenings but us
hey we gotta talk about the trailer but first the
word from our sponsor Disney speed storm now I'm
gonna take a moment to be brutally honest with you
guys hearing about this game and while the concept
of it actually sounded pretty cool a little bit on
the fence as to whether or not it would actually
be good part of the process that was required
was to you know get some game capture footage
of one of us playing the game I took on the heavy
burden of being the one to play the game truly a
brave and Noble decision the goal was just to sit
down for 10 minutes here is just the time stamp of
the raw footage I ended up playing this game for
nearly a solid hour he did yeah John was recording
me the whole time and almost every single time
I was done with a race I was like one time just
looking at the trailer I already thought that the
game looked really cool because I immediately got
what it was about you get to play as a variety
of Disney and Pixar characters in awesome awesome
racing levels but it's more than just a cool
concept the game is a genuine blast now I played
An Early Access version of the game on Steam I
tried a bunch of different characters like Mulan
Meg Jack Sparrow beast and I got to play through
a variety of these insanely Vivid levels that are
just brought to life in these intricately fleshed
out ways and the characters dialogue also has this
accurate representation of them power sets and
melee weapons while being involved in the race
make for a truly fun competitive gameplay one
thing that stood out to me that might seem like
an odd thing to point out was the inclusion of
the drift in the gameplay where it truly is a
necessary part of doing the races and obstacles
as opposed to just feeling like an added bonus so
needless to say yeah this is a glowing endorsement
for those who stream there is a streamer mode
available which will replace the licensed Disney
music however when I'm playing in the Disney music
is going off during the races it makes it feel so
much more lived in and there's some other things
we have to mention to you guys so John why don't
you take it Disney speedstorm is now available in
Early Access for players who purchase a Founders
pack this includes immediate racer unlocks a large
Grant of tokens which is the in-game currency as
well as golden past credits you'll get exclusive
limited time items such as racing suits cart
liveries customization parts and more and as
a Founder you get to keep all these rewards even
after the official launch so during Early Access
you can enjoy both single player and multiplayer
mode leaderboards in-game shop multiplayer modes
include local free play Private track ranked
multiplayer with leaderboards and regulated
multiplayer where players race head to head on an
even playing field rev your engines and join the
fun like I almost by like I watched you do visit
the Disney speedstorm by checking out our link
below in the description box and pin comment and
a massive thank you to Disney Speedster sponsoring
this video because in the game truly was rewarding
any new imagery we get of The Flash I'm excited
for because this film does look freaking awesome
and the word of mouth in this movie is phenomenal
Stephen King highly recommends this movie
apparently and he is honest when he doesn't
like something very honest so if Stephen King's
got a stamp of approval then you know it's got
to be something good I am glad this is the final
trailer that being said because they're they're
they are showing quite a lot at this point and I
feel like after the last trailer it's pretty much
able to piece together how most of this movie is
ultimately gonna go down right up until you get to
that finale it's pretty obvious which moment in
this movie is going to be the big finale in the
desert with the world engine and all that so
it's going to be a big CGI Fest that I can't
wait to go check out but I really am surprised
by how much Ben Affleck they're actually leading
with this time it seems like before it was
so much Michael Keaton in this trailer was
like Ben Affleck's trailer yeah there was so
much bat Fleck here and I feel like he's not
in the movie that long so I'm like looking
avoid all of it even though it looks really
cool yeah all of it away uh but yeah overall I
thought this was a really fun trailer still yeah
I mean this might be just tonally and just imagery
wise my favorite just because it does look both
fun but also a bit intense a bit emotional and
yeah I like that it is the bat Fleck trailer
and it seems like he's gonna have that one major
action scene on the bike and then a few scenes
with Barry but that was always a part of you know
even the Zack Snyder or Joss Whedon versions of
Justice League that I enjoyed a lot was Flash uh
was Barry and Bruce that Ben Affleck Bruce so you
know I mean as much as I'm like keep as much as
you can for the movie I was enlivened by seeing
them in that capacity in this trailer plus some of
the Fish Out of Water stuff like with him having
to tackle his younger self and like straighten
things out it seemed it communicated a bit more
fun than a lot of the trailers prior to this have
at least in terms of like oh yeah there at least
be some kind of whimsical fish out of watery stuff
yeah it seems like they're doing everything that
we've been hearing it's this trailer LED with so
much emotion we got to see Iris West we gotta see
uh hear the mom speak a little bit more as well uh
the temptation of the choice and I'm even trying
to convince Ben Affleck at the beginning I could
save even your parents uh yeah I think there's
a real good debate here that they are setting
up like a good moral quandary at its Center as
well so this does feel very heartfelt and it seems
like there's so much great humor and the visuals
just continue to be more and more impressive uh
because like it's weird even when it looks like
heavy CGI to me yeah when I'm like this is so
apparently CGI I still think it looks gorgeous
even when I'm like this doesn't look real but I
still think it looks great yeah yeah it's really
bizarre to me I I don't often say that normally I
find that that quality uh distracting but no this
was an awesome ass trailer and I can't wait
to see it very very soon hopefully we can get
to another screen and get you guys a review as
soon as possible but ladies and gentlemen what
did you think about this Flash trailer leave
your thoughts down below be sure to subscribe
uh leave a like keep a lookout for when we got
a review over here on this channel and hey we
will chat with you all very very soon thank you
to Disney needs more for sponsoring this video